This is the brief on Meshtastic
infrastructure deployment.
So we're looking at a personal
story, right?
It's about someone who took a
cheap off the shelf Meshtastic
Laura device and figured out
what it really takes to make
these off grid networks actually
work.
OK, first up, physical placement
is everything for Laura Radio.
This person was on the 8th floor
and they found that just being
up high with a totally clear
line of sight was the biggest
deal.
You know that clean path for the
radio signal?
It's called a Fresnel zone and
keeping it clear is just
crucial.
Basically, where you put the
thing matters more than any
fancy settings or expensive gear
you could buy.
All right.
Second, once you've got the
placement sorted, it's all about
stability.
You have to treat the device
like permanent infrastructure,
not a personal gadget.
So it's role was changed from a
sleeping node to a dedicated
always on router.
This meant disabling settings
like deep sleep, since it was
always plugged into the wall
anyway.
It was even given a neutral
name, Abracadabra, to show it
was a community asset.
And finally, the last lesson is,
well, the goal is to be boring.
Meshtastic is at its best when
the whole system is so stable
you just forget it's even there.
It's that quiet, consistent up
time where the node is just
doing its job routing traffic in
the background.
That's what really makes the
whole network stronger for
everyone.
So really stability, placement
and uptime are what truly
transform a simple gadget into
resilient infrastructure.
Welcome to the deep dive.
The place where we, you know, we
really try to cut through the
noise and deliver the critical
insights you need to truly
understand the mechanics of the
world around us.
Today we are setting aside,
well, everything we normally
talk about 5G fiber optics.
We're going to explore something
radically different, a
fascinating world of
decentralized off grid
communication built on low power
radio technology.
A technology called mesh tastic.
Exactly mesh tastic.
And this is, I think, a really
perfect deep dive into
resilience.
We're tracing the journey of one
specific user, someone who
bought a cheap gadget purely out
of curiosity, and we get to
watch them almost transform.
Into what exactly?
Into a critical permanent piece
of their local communities,
digital infrastructure.
The sources we have today, they
just chronicle this entire
evolution, mapping the shift
from, you know, a $55 purchase
to an essential network
backbone.
And that's the core mission
today for you, the listener.
We're analyzing this fundamental
shift, how a minimal initial
investment combined with a
crucial insight about the
physics of radio and, well, the
nature of network needs, turns a
personal experiment into a
public utility.
Yeah, our focus will be on the
technical details behind this
transformation, tracing the user
Chris Abrahams experience from
the moment he first powered it
on to, well, stabilizing a
permanent routing node in the
busy mesh DC area.
And the underlying concept here
is so critical for for a modern
communication resilience.
We're exploring how small
accessible hardware can let you
just circumvent these fragile
centralized systems like cell
towers or Wi-Fi hubs.
But it's not just about the
tech.
No, not at all.
To make this work, there's this
required and I'd say often
uncomfortable shift in mindset.
You have to move from thinking
about individual convenience to
prioritizing network wide
stability, communal presence.
OK, let's unpack this starting
at the absolute beginning.
The user, as you said, wasn't a
prepper, not a licensed ham
radio operator.
It was just a low buying
curiosity spurred by how
accessible the technology has
become.
He bought a cheap purple
Meshtastic device off Etsy for
about 55 bucks.
That's the key, that price
point.
That's the open door for this
whole experiment, right?
So what exactly is Meshtastic,
and why is it structured to be
so approachable for someone who
isn't, you know, a radio expert?
Mesh Tastic is fundamentally an
open source system.
It's designed to facilitate a
short text messaging and
location sharing over something
called Laura Radio.
OK, the genius of the project
isn't just the hardware, which
is usually cheap off the shelf
components like ESP 32
microcontrollers.
The genius is the open source
firmware that wraps it all up.
It makes it simple.
It makes setup as easy as
pairing a Bluetooth device to
your phone.
And critically for local
operation, it requires
absolutely no centralized
external services, no cellular,
no Wi-Fi.
It's entirely self-contained.
So let's dig into the core
technology that's powering this,
which is Laura.
This is the bedrock.
We use Wi-Fi and 5G everyday.
Why is Laura the right choice
for this kind of decentralized
resilient application, even
though it's, I mean, painfully
slow compared to the
alternatives?
That slowness is its superpower.
It really is.
Laura stands for Long Range and
it uses a technique called Ship
Spread Spectrum or CSS
modulation and this is a
deliberate, highly effective
trade off.
A trade off of what?
For what?
It sacrifices high bandwidth and
you are definitely not sending
photos here.
You're sending maybe what, 20
bytes of text at a time?
OK.
And in exchange it maximizes 2
things, distance and efficiency.
Because the data rate is so
incredibly low, you can pull the
signal out of the noise floor
over vast distances.
We're talking far exceeding
typical line of sight limits for
other radio types at the same
power level.
So if I'm understanding this
correctly, the network
designers, they looked at the
requirements, you know, sending
a basic text message or location
update during an emergency and
they said we don't need a
massive digital highway, we just
need a robust low energy trail.
Exactly.
It's optimized for minimal data
transfer and maximum resilience.
These devices can run for weeks,
sometimes a month, on battery
power, because they only need to
transmit these tiny little
packets of data every now and
then.
And that efficiency, that's what
makes the network sustainable
and cheap to maintain.
It's perfect for status updates
and critical short
communication.
Now we have to move to the
concept that really defines the
utility of the system, which is
the mesh.
This is the crucial
architectural difference that
provides all that resilience.
Let's compare this structurally
to the centralized model most of
us are used to.
Right.
So as you said, standard
cellular or even your home Wi-Fi
is centralized.
It follows a hub and spoke
model.
One to many.
One to many if that central hub,
the cell tower or your router.
If it fails the spoke, your
phone or computer is just
completely disconnected.
Game over.
The mesh concept is, well, it's
anarchic in the best possible
way.
Every device, every node
communicates directly with its
neighbors.
And here's the key feature mesh
Tastic enables.
Every node can act as a fully
autonomous relay.
So my device isn't just talking
to the network, it's actively
being the network for other
people.
Precisely, if you send a message
and the destination node is too
far away for your radio to reach
directly your closest neighbor
node, it just grabs that packet,
stores it for a millisecond, and
then forwards it to its
neighbor, and so on.
So messages can take multiple
hops.
Multiple.
Hops and Machastic manages all
this through an adaptive routing
protocol.
It automatically builds and
maintains a table of known
neighbors and what it thinks are
the most efficient paths.
I get the resilience advantage.
Redundancy means no single point
of failure.
But here's question if every
node is constantly relaying
traffic, isn't that a massive
drag on the battery life of the
average person who's just
carrying this device in their
pocket?
How does the network stop the
core relay nodes from getting
overwhelmed?
Or you know, just draining all
the mobile users power.
That's a highly relevant
technical challenge and it goes
directly to the resource
management strategy of the
firmware.
OK, mesh Tastic firmware is
built to manage this
intelligently.
First, because Laura
transmissions are so incredibly
power efficient, the energy cost
of forwarding a small text
packet is minimal.
It's often far less than the
cost of you trying and failing
to reach the destination
directly with a higher power
broadcast.
So it's actually more efficient
to whisper to your neighbor than
to shout across the valley.
That's a great way to put it.
Second, the network limits the
number of hops a message can
take.
This prevents infinite loops and
just uncontrolled flooding of
the network with junk packets.
Sure, makes sense.
And 3rd Meshtastic uses this
intelligent neighbor discovery.
It prioritizes strong stable
links, which inherently favors
stationary powered nodes over
the mobile transient ones.
And that dynamic prioritization
that sounds critical, it really
sets the stage for our users
journey.
So if the network itself favors
stability, the core value
proposition for you, the
listener, isn't about replacing
anything.
It's about insuring against
failure.
Exactly.
This technology acts as a
resilient complement.
It's not about high throughput,
it's about guaranteed message
delivery.
When traditional infrastructure
fails during a localized power
outage, a communications
blackout, a natural disaster,
anything like that, it provides
this crucial layer of
communication independence,
ensuring those essential short
messages, are you safe, where
are you can get through
regardless of what's happening
with a utility grid.
It effectively transforms
communication from a
centralized, paid service into a
decentralized, collaboratively
built utility.
That's a profound shift in
control.
It really is.
So let's pivot now to the user
specific experience, because
that really highlights this
philosophical shift from being a
user to being a component of the
utility when the user first
activated their cheap purple
gadget.
The source material describes
this initial sense of, well,
disappointment.
It worked, but it didn't feel
like a functioning network.
Yeah.
Why was there that disconnect?
The disappointment?
It stemmed entirely from
centralized expectations.
He paired it, sent a few test
messages, and just watched the
node list fluctuate wildly.
So people were just popping in
and out.
Constantly nodes would appear,
transmit maybe once, and then
vanish.
Traffic was sparse.
The user observed that most
activity just look like people
checking in, not sustained
routing behavior.
It felt ephemeral.
Right.
It felt like a collection of
individual experiments rather
than a true network fabric.
I mean, if you're used to
checking your Wi-Fi status and
seeing 20 neighboring networks,
this quiet inconsistent
behavior, it feels like a
failure.
The technology was doing its
job, but the critical mass of of
community presence wasn't there
yet to make it feel robust.
And then the user made this
tiny, almost trivial decision
that changed absolutely
everything.
The first meaningful decision,
uptime, is everything.
He just left it on.
He simply left the device
plugged in and running
indefinitely, and he admitted
this decision didn't feel
consequential at the time.
You know, he was busy, he forgot
about it, but it stayed on.
And that single act was the
catalyst for his transformation
into an infrastructure
component.
And this action embodies that
key, almost paradoxical insight
about decentralized systems like
Mesh Tastic.
The network doesn't reward
active interaction, it rewards
continuous stable presence.
This is a critical technical
insight wrapped in a simple
behavioral choice.
It's so important in a mesh.
Unstable nodes, those that turn
on for 30 minutes and then
disappear.
They actually create friction.
How so?
They cause what we call route
flapping.
The network learns a route
through that node, it starts
sending traffic that way, and
then the node vanishes.
This forces the entire network
to waste energy recalculating
the path and retransmitting the
message.
It's inefficient.
Highly inefficient nodes that
stay up and maintain constant
presence.
They become statistical anchors.
They're reliable hops.
They increase increase the
successful hop count across the
mesh, confirming the network
stability and over time.
Other nodes actively prefer
routing through them because
they know that connection will
be maintained.
So stability minimizes
inefficiency for everyone else.
By simply existing reliably, the
user began reducing the power
consumption and increasing the
reliability for every other
mobile user in his region.
Precisely.
He went from being a consumer
occasionally checking in, to
being a foundational, silent
contributor to a public utility.
And this is where the identity
shift came into play.
Right.
The name he initially used Abra,
which was short for his name
Abraham, But he realized it felt
too personal for what was
becoming a public resource.
And that realization is the
final cognitive leap.
It's the one you have to make to
transition from user to
architect.
Infrastructure can't be tied to
an individual's identity.
So what did he do?
He kept the identifier abra, but
he redefined it.
He changed it to abracadabra.
Abracadabra.
And this name choice is perfect.
It's abstract, it's memorable,
it's playfully neutral, and most
importantly, it communicates
that this node is autonomous.
It's not subject to the personal
whims of the operator.
It's a signal to other.
It's signals this is a permanent
stationary relay point ready for
community use.
The device itself was telling a
story of commitment even before
he really optimized the physical
setup.
But commitment only goes so far
without physics backing it up.
And here's where it gets really
interesting.
The source material emphasizes
that the physical location
determined the device's success
more than any software setting.
Oh.
Absolutely.
You just can't.
Software patch badge geography.
That is the absolute truth of
radio frequency communications,
especially when you're using
Laura's low power.
The user lives on the 8th floor
in Arlington Heights.
His windows face southeast.
Which turned out to be critical.
Critical.
He quickly realized, just
through simple observation, that
he had an entirely unobstructed
line of sight.
His view cleared a golf course
and a significant stretch of low
rise terrain projecting all the
way toward the Gaylord MGM area.
That elevation in Clearview, I
mean, it's worth thousands of
dollars in commercial radio
equipment upgrades, but here it
was just the reality of his
lease agreement.
It's the ultimate geographical
advantage for Laura.
Placing is paramount because
you're trying to overcome the
Earth's curve and ground level
obstructions.
And this brings us to a key
piece of jargon we really need
to unpack, which is the Fresnel
zone.
The Fresnel zone OK, it's often
confused with simple line of
sight, but you're saying it's
far more complex.
It is so Tell us what a Fresnel
zone is and why was that golf
course so important to its
success?
OK, so think of a radio
transmission not as a single
thin laser beam of light, but as
an expanding ellipse, like a
football shape around the Direct
Line of sight between two
antennas.
The Fresnel zone is this
required elliptical area, the
first Fresnel zone specifically.
That has to be kept clear of
obstructions to ensure you get
maximum signal strength.
If 60% or more of that ellipse
is obstructed by something,
signal quality degrades
dramatically.
Even if you can still visually
see the other antenna.
Exactly.
That's the counterintuitive
part.
So even if the user could see
the Gaylord MGM, if they had a
dense tree line or small hill
just below their Direct Line of
sight, even though it wasn't
blocking the view.
The radio waves that are
traveling in that football shape
around the direct pass would
still be degraded.
Precisely.
Objects like buildings, dense
foliage, even the surface of the
ground, they cause reflections
and phase cancellation.
We call it multipath
interference.
The golf course and the low rise
terrain provided the ideal,
almost pristine clearance
required for that Fresnel zone.
So the signal could just
propagate smoothly over vast
distances.
The environment was doing the
vast majority of the heavy
lifting.
The user had cheap hardware but
$1,000,000 RF location.
Once that physical reality was
recognized, the logical
conclusion was that the device
could no longer be treated like
a casual gadget.
Correct.
When the user cemented the nodes
stationary status, you know the
purple box the whip antenna
always powered basically bolted
down metaphorically in the
window.
He realized treating it as a
standard node was just wasted
potential.
Because a standard node is
designed for portability and
sleep.
Right.
A device in such a prime RF
location that is allowed to
sleep to save power even for a
few hours is just fundamentally
misaligned with its physical
advantage.
Then drove the functional change
in the software, switching the
device role from a standard node
to a dedicated router.
And this was the functional
declaration of its new
infrastructure identity.
The Router role ensures the
device is awake and actively
forwarding messages, maximizing
its contribution to stability
and range for the entire Mesh DC
community.
It signifies that the operator
has accepted that
responsibility.
Yes, they've accepted the
responsibility of maintaining a
key network relay, moving beyond
just personal use to community
service.
But switching to router mode
introduced a significant
friction point.
The device's internal behavior
changed in ways the Phone A
didn't really explain well, and
this led to a lot of frustration
for the user.
What was the core technical
conflict that emerged here?
The conflict was architectural,
and it all stemmed from power
management.
When you designate a node as a
router, the firmware scheduler,
it aggressively prioritizes the
core mission.
Which is maintaining the radio
link and processing packets.
Exactly, and to achieve this
reliability and conserve power
in the general case for a
battery device, it de
prioritizes non essential
functions, particularly the
control plane access via
Bluetooth Low Energy or BLE.
So the device was doing its job
perfectly, routing traffic
silently and efficiently, but
the human operator trying to
connect with their phone
suddenly found the device
inconsistent and hard to manage.
Exactly, from a phone centric
perspective it just felt buggy.
You try to connect via the app
and it would time out or fail
because the BLE control plane
was scheduled to sleep or delay
interrupts to give the radio
stack priority.
And this also minimizes
potential self interference,
right?
Right.
Any processing power diverted to
maintaining a constant BLE
connection is power not
available for radio
transmission, or it might induce
noise into the RF chain.
The device was maximizing
network utility at the expense
of user convenience.
And this really highlights why
troubleshooting these
decentralized tools so often
requires bypassing the simple
app interface and digging
deeper.
You have to.
The user access the device over
USB to view the console and the
actual configuration settings.
What are that technical deep
dive reveal?
It confirmed the scheduling
conflict.
The control plane was indeed
sleeping or being heavily
deferred while the radio link
remained continuously active.
The user realized that while
this aggressive power saving was
essential for a battery powered
device out in the field.
It was completely unnecessary
for his permanent wall powered
setup.
Totally unnecessary.
He had unlimited power but was
suffering the usability
consequences of a power
constrained configuration.
So since power was no longer
scarce, the device was
permanently plugged into a USBC
wall wart.
He was free to compromise
efficiency for stability and
convenience.
This is a fascinating trade off
using an abundance of power to
solve a human interaction
problem.
It is.
What were the three specific
configuration adjustments he
made to stabilize that control
plane?
The three investments were
highly targeted.
They were specifically aimed at
just over ruling those power
saving defaults.
First, he explicitly disabled
deep sleep entirely.
The node would never enter a low
power state, ensuring instant
responsive.
OK, that's a big one.
Second, he significantly
increased the Bluetooth wait
time or the BLE advertising
interval.
This just extended the window
during which the device's
control plane remained available
to accept connections from the
phone.
Mitigating those intermittent
connection issues.
Yep and 3rd he just left the
display on full time showing
status information.
Let's look at that first change
for a second.
Disabling deep sleep while they
have unlimited power, Are there
any negative consequences for
the hardware or the surrounding
environment, like excessive heat
or reduced component lifespan?
That's a crucial technical
nuance the sources imply but
don't really dwell on.
And yes, disabling deep sleep
means the microcontroller is
running at a higher clock speed
and duty cycle constantly.
This generates more heat.
Of course, and in these cheap
mass produced enclosures like
the $55 purple box, this
continuous heat can absolutely
reduce the lifespan of the
internal components,
particularly the capacitors and
the SO itself.
So for a cheap router, this
might just be acceptable wear
and tear.
It's a trade off.
You maximize lifetime stability
at the potential cost of
component longevity.
He chose maximal operational
stability, now accepting that
the device might fail earlier
than if it were managed more
conservatively.
And the result once these
changes were implemented was
stabilization.
Yes, the device stopped
oscillating between states, the
BLE access became reliably
instant, and crucially, none of
these adjustments compromised
the device score routing
function.
In fact, keeping it fully awake
arguably improved its routing
responsiveness.
So he successfully molded the
aggressive, power constrained
router architecture into a
stable, convenient piece of
permanent infrastructure.
And once that stability was
achieved, the user noted, the
ultimate goal was reached.
The device became boring.
Boring is best for
infrastructure.
Absolutely.
When a router is stable, doing
its job well, you should never
have to interact with it.
If you are constantly
troubleshooting your relay node,
it is failing its primary
purpose.
The abracadabra node settled
into its optimal state.
Silent, reliable, consistently
forwarding traffic and just
radiating its signal perfectly
from that 8th floor window.
So while the user was busy
taming their individual router,
the surround surrounding local
network in the Arlington and
Mesh DC area was simultaneously
maturing.
The user noted an increase in
traffic and stability that was
coinciding with his adjustments.
This was a synergistic effect.
The stabilization of key relay
nodes like abracadabra created
this positive feedback loop.
The local network began
converging on a preferred
configuration standard.
The long fast preset.
The long fast preset and this
preset is a critical middle
ground in the Laura settings.
OK, So what exactly does long
fast balance and how does it
compare to other choices like
long slow?
So Meshtastic let's operators
choose different combinations of
spreading factor or SF bandwidth
and coding rate.
Long slow, which prioritizes
maximum range, often uses a very
high spreading factor.
This makes messages extremely
slow.
We're talking seconds to
transmit a single text packet
and it consumes a lot of
airtime.
Clogging up the frequency.
Right long fast sacrifices a
tiny bit of that maximum
theoretical range by using a
slightly lower F and a higher
bandwidth.
This results in much faster
transmissions, reducing the time
the radio occupies the airwaves.
Reducing the duty cycle.
Exactly which is crucial in
congested urban or suburban
areas.
It's the sweet spot for a
functioning medium speed mesh.
And the maturation of the
network was visible not just in
the volume of messages, but in
key performance indicators like
increase hop counts and improved
ACK frequency.
Let's define those for the
listener.
Sure, an ACK is a simple
acknowledgement.
It's a confirmation signal sent
back to the originating device
that the message was
successfully received by the
intended recipient.
So it's a delivery receipt.
It's a delivery receipt, and in
a robust mesh, a high ACK
frequency confirms that messages
aren't just being broadcast
blindly into the void.
They're traversing the mesh,
being successfully relayed
through multiple hops, and
reaching their destination
reliably.
And the increased hop counts.
Increased hop counts mean
messages are successfully
traveling four or five or even 6
nodes deep.
That shows the physical range
and depth of the network has
increased significantly.
It's using stable nodes like the
8th floor Abracadabra node to
bridge previously unreachable
gaps.
So the local RF network was
humming along quietly proving
its decentralized resilience.
But then the user decided to
connect the node to the Internet
via MQTT.
This is a critical point where
the local physical network
touches the global digital map.
And this step is purely for
visibility and legibility.
He enabled MQTT, the Message
Queuing Telemetry transport
protocol, which is perfect for
publishing small pieces of data
over the Internet.
What date is it sending?
The node sends metadata about
itself, its identity, its
location, its last act of time,
and its known neighbors to a
centralized public broker.
This data then appears on the
global Meshtastic map.
Now, it is absolutely crucial to
clarify the distinction here.
Enabling NQDT does not mean your
text messages are suddenly being
sent over the Internet.
Absolutely not.
Local messaging remains 100%
over the Laura radio waves.
The message content itself is
not compromised by the Internet
connection.
It's just a status update.
MQTT simply provides global
visibility to the nodes
metadata.
It abstracts that physical
purple box in the window into a
legible digital icon on a map,
which allows the wider mesh
tastic community to understand
where coverage exists.
It's an operational status
report, not a communication
conduit.
So if the power grid failed
locally, the radio communication
would continue completely
unedated, but the icon on the
global map would simply go
offline.
That's the precise
functionality.
The local resilience is
maintained.
The Internet connection is
strictly a convenience for meta
level coordination and mapping.
And this leads us to a
fascinating paradox which was
highlighted by the user's
experience.
These two distinct layers of
operation, you have the physical
decentralized radial layer and
then you have the meta human
coordination layer.
It's the centralization of
decentralization.
It's a great term for it.
The user noted that almost all
the meta work coordinating which
preset to use, like long fast
troubleshooting community wide
outages, debating optimal node
placement, and generally
managing regional awareness.
It all happens entirely off
network.
Primarily this happens through
platforms like the Mesh DC
Discord server.
Right, the RF layer is
decentralized, silent and
passive.
It's just route and traffic
based on physics and
programming, but the human
element it requires
coordination, discussion and
consensus, which by human nature
centralizes onto a platform like
Discord.
So you need a centralized place
to discuss how to optimize the
decentralized system.
It's a paradox, but it works.
This is where the community
decides, for instance, that
abracadabra is a critical relay
and should always be configured
to use the fastest possible long
fast preset to maximize the
benefit for the whole community.
So the technology offers total
independence, but the human
requirement for efficiency and
coordination pulls the community
back toward a centralized
virtual space to make decisions
about that independent network.
It proves that even when the
means of communication are
decentralized, the
organizational structure of the
people using it will often
centralized just to be
effective.
The Discord server acts as the
essential non decentralized
command Center for managing the
decentralized RF infrastructure.
This journey from a skeptical
purchase on Etsy to a key
infrastructural node has
provided some really profound
technical and philosophical
insights.
So what does this all mean?
The central lesson learned by
Chris Abraham wasn't just about
radio settings, it was a lesson
in effective contribution.
Meshtastic works best when the
operator sheds the mindset of a
personal user and embraces the
commitment of being stable,
reliable infrastructure.
And we learned that real
infrastructure success hinges on
three simple factors.
Stability, optimal placement
driven by physics, and most
importantly, continuous uptime.
The user didn't need specialized
training or massive funding.
He simply left a cheap device
plugged into a strategically
high, well placed window.
The network stability, the
community's range, the overall
functionality, it all flowed
naturally from that single
persistent act of presence.
It's a remarkable testament to
the power of low effort, high
impact commitment in a
distributed system.
It fundamentally reframes what
contribution means.
In a digital, decentralized age,
sometimes the most valuable
thing you can contribute isn't
active work or complex
interaction, but simply existing
reliably in a good spot for the
benefit of the collective.
And this contrasts so sharply
with the tragedy of the Commons,
where individuals act selfishly
to the detriment of the group
resource.
In Mesh Tastic, we see the
rewards of the consistent
contributor.
By prioritizing continuous
stable presence, the Abracadabra
node didn't just help its owner,
it increased the efficiency and
resilience of every other node,
thereby rewarding the entire
community.
Which raises an important
question for you, the learner,
to consider as you move forward.
If a reliable resilient network
can be quietly built piece by
piece by individuals who
prioritize persistent presence
over momentary interaction, what
other types of decentralized
resilient systems could benefit
from the exact same set it and
forget it commitment?
It's a powerful idea.
What local infrastructure,
whether a digital relay node, a
physical community resource, or
even just consistent positive
participation, could you
contribute to just by staying
reliably present?
Think about the power of boring
stability in a hyperactive
world.
OK, so this critique is about
the journey of taking a $55
Laura Meshtastic device and
turning it into a stable, always
on piece of infrastructure.
A router?
Yeah, from an eighth floor
apartment.
Exactly.
And the core discovery here,
which I think is just brilliant,
is that Meshtastic rewards
presence more than interaction.
So let's just dive right in on
how to make the material around
that idea even stronger for the
community.
First off, that conclusion you
wrote the node became boring,
and boring is the goal.
Oh, that's the best line.
It's just, it's gold.
It perfectly captures that shift
from a gadget you're fiddling
with to, you know, real
infrastructure.
It really does.
It's so relatable.
I mean, anyone who's ever run a
server knows that exact feeling
of relief when things just go
quiet.
Right.
But, and here's the thing, how
does the community measure your
success?
That feeling of boring is great
for you, the operator, but for
the mesh network itself it's not
really verifiable.
Yeah, that's the tension right
there, and it's our first point.
While boring is the goal is a
perfect narrative ending,
defining what makes it boring
could turn this personal insight
into a measurable standard for
everyone.
Because right now success is
just defined as it stopped
needing attention.
Exactly, which for a new person
setting up a router, that's not
a target they can really aim
for.
You need proof you're actually
helping.
OK, but let me push back on that
for a second.
We are talking about a volunteer
hobbyist network here.
True.
Is there a risk that if we start
enforcing, you know, rigid
performance metrics, KPIs and
all that, we might actually
scare people off?
We don't want to turn running a
node into a high pressure IT
job.
That's a really valid concern
and we absolutely have to keep
it light.
We're not talking about like
enterprise level SL as or
anything, OK?
The suggestion is more to just
codify what that boring state
looks like.
Maybe two or three high level
objective things that show the
routers doing its job.
A checklist.
So less of an operational metric
for the owner and more of a
contribution metric for the
mesh.
Yes, exactly.
OK, I like that distinction.
So what if what if we focused on
visibility?
Since you mentioned seeing more
long, fast traffic sticking
around, right?
Let's propose something like a
minimum consistent neighbor
count.
Just a simple metric that tracks
how many other nodes reliably
see ABRA day in and day out.
That proves persistence without
getting too granular.
That is super actionable, and to
build on that we could also
track the data it's forwarding
that isn't its own data.
So a.
Forwarding rate, A sustained
packet forwarding rate, Yeah.
It doesn't have to be some
specific number, just something
that shows it's actively passing
traffic for other people.
It makes its contribution
totally undeniable.
And the beauty of those two
specific KPI is that they would
perfectly visualize the story
you're already telling.
How so?
You could create a simple graph,
just a mock up, show how
unstable the neighbor count and
forwarding rate were in the
beginning that whole gadget
phase.
Right, all over the place.
And then show how flat and
reliable the lines are now in
the infrastructure phase.
That visual makes the whole
point of the documentation
concrete.
It's powerful.
Making the invisible work
visible.
I love it.
That gives every operator a real
target to aim for.
OK, so let's shift gears a bit
from network metrics to the
actual device mechanics.
The troubleshooting.
Yes, because there's one section
in here that needs to be like,
shouted from the rooftops.
That whole process of switching
to router mode and dealing with
the Bluetooth weirdness that is
such a vital counterintuitive
knowledge. 100% it's where
everyone gets stuck.
And what I appreciate is the
honesty.
You really detail that friction.
You know the clash between phone
centric expectations and the
reality of a radio centric
device.
Oh, that's exactly the friction
point.
The device is designed by
default to save battery, right?
So it's sleeps, it pauses
Bluetooth, it's meant to be
interactive, but stable
infrastructure needs to be
present, it needs to be always
listening.
And that feeling when you can't
even connect to your own router
to check the logs is just.
It's mad.
I've been there, right?
So the narrative of finding the
fix is great, but the risk here
is that the actual solution gets
buried in the story.
If someone's looking for a quick
technical fix, they have to read
through the whole saga to piece
together the checklist of what
you did.
That's true.
You should probably isolate it,
but I do wonder if you pull it
out completely, do you lose that
crucial teaching moment?
The why is almost more important
than the what.
How do you mean?
Well, if you just give a
checklist that says disable deep
sleep, people might lose the
context that the only reason
that's OK is because the device
is now permanently plugged in.
The normal power saving rules
just don't apply anymore.
That's a very sharp point.
OK.
So we need a hybrid structure.
The suggestion is to pull out
the fixes into a dedicated
actionable section like a router
stability recipe, but we have to
build that context right into
it.
I like that a recipe.
Yeah, and it reinforces the core
message.
Stable infrastructure needs non
default settings that kind of
defy portable logic.
OK, so let's make it a super
visible 3 point checklist.
Lay it out for me.
Number one, power management
override.
You know, disable deep sleep 2
control plane access, increase
that Bluetooth wait time and
three visibility keep the
display on.
And the key part?
Pocket of title for that
section.
Oh yeah, something like the
paradox of router stability.
Why you must override power
management?
Oh, that's excellent.
The title itself tells the
story.
It elevates those steps from
just a personal anecdote into
like a community best practice.
Yeah, it tells the reader that
the pain they're feeling is
normal.
It's part of becoming an
infrastructure steward, not just
a device owner.
OK.
So that moves us to our final
critique, which is all about
physical advantage location.
Prime real estate.
Absolutely.
I mean 8th floor Arlington
Heights, unobstructed view over
a golf course towards the
Gaylord MGM.
You can't buy that.
The environment is doing half
the work.
It's a critical, scarce asset.
Seriously, in a dense area like
DC or Arlington, a high up
vantage point with a clear line
of sight is so rare.
So the node is doing a great job
routing traffic, but just having
it be a passive relay feels like
an underutilization of that
spot.
It should be an active reference
point for the whole local mesh
DC network.
So the opportunity here is an
evolution of Aber's role.
Shift it from just a reliable
router to a reference node.
A benchmark.
Yeah, a benchmark used for
standardized testing, feeding
actionable data back to the
community on Discord.
Given the stability we just
talked about, it's perfectly
positioned to be an anchor.
Exactly.
If you have the best, most
stable location, you shouldn't
just be a relay, you should be
the measurement stick.
To leave it passive is to miss
the chance to turn it into a
living piece of diagnostic
equipment for everyone.
O What are the concrete,
actionable steps to make that
happen, to make it an active
reference node?
Okay, a few options.
We can start simple.
The first suggestion is to
coordinate structured signal
checks in the Discord group.
So that's just a social thing,
no new hardware.
Zero new hardware, it's just
coordination.
You get people who are driving
or walking around to try and hit
Abra from known geographic
points.
Abra's telemetry then serves as
the consistent benchmark and the
community can actually map the
real world limits of the network
in the region.
That's brilliant maximizing the
location for 0 cost, but we
could push it further.
You could.
Since it's permanently installed
and power is no object, what
about suggesting adding some
simple low power environmental
sensors?
Like air quality or barometric
pressure?
Yeah, and publish that telemetry
over MQTT.
Now, Abra isn't just a message
relay, it's a consistent,
stationary data rich resource
for the area.
And and importantly, since the
documentation mentions the
identity shift from the personal
abra to the more abstract
abracadabra, right, you should
lean into that.
Frame the node as an official
beacon or anchor in the
community docs.
It totally cements its role as a
communal asset, not just
someone's personal gadget.
So yeah, we've covered a lot of
ground here, but it's all about
taking this already strong
documentation and just
maximizing its value for the
whole mesh tested community.
The foundation is absolutely
there.
You built the stable piece,
which is what a decentralized
network desperately needs.
These next steps are just about
visibility and accountability.
To quickly summarize the three
main areas for growth, then
first operationalize that idea
of boring success into community
KPIs.
Focus on packet forwarding and
neighbor count to prove its
contribution right.
Second, pull out those critical
router configuration fixes into
a clear, actionable router
stability recipe for maximum
utility.
The paradox of stability.
Love that.
And third, evolve the Aber node
from a passive router into an
active data rich reference node
by using its premium 8th floor
placement for community wide
benchmarking.
You implement those changes and
this goes from being great
documentation to setting a high
value community standard.
We are really looking forward to
seeing the update.
And if you're listening and
working on similar
infrastructure docs, or really
any project that could use a
sharp, constructive lens, we
invite you to submit your work
for a future critique.
Welcome to the debate.
We are diving into a a really
crucial paradox that's coming up
with the deployment of
Meshtastic networks.
Does success in decentralized
communication hinge more on
smart geography or on smart
engineering?
We're going to use this case
study of a single node in the
Arlington Mesh DC area, a
personal gadget that really
became a piece of core network
infrastructure, to explore
whether it's the physical laws
of radio or the conscious human
layers of configuration that
deserve the credit.
And that case study is perfect
because it really highlights the
tension, right?
When a low power mesh network,
something relying on lower
radio, actually becomes
reliable, like this Abracadabra
node.
Did we have to ask why?
What allowed it to stop being,
you know, just a curiosity and
start being a real utility?
The physical environment is
obviously a prerequisite, but
I'm going to argue that the
decision points, the moments of
deliberate human choice, are
what ultimately unlocked that
stability.
So the central disagreement is
pretty clear in the success of a
system like mestastic, what
holds primary important I'm
going to argue for the primacy
of well physical infrastructure
physics and share presence.
The material we're looking at
even states that the system
doesn't reward interaction as
much as it rewards presence.
And I have to challenge that
entirely.
For me, it's the abstracted
human and configuration layers
that are the true determinants
of utility.
They're what transform passive,
well placed hardware into
active, reliable infrastructure
that a community can actually
depend on.
Without that deliberate
technical choice, that well
placed radio is just, well, it's
wasted potential.
OK, let's start with the
evidence for physics.
The most critical factor in this
nodes transformation was simply
placement.
The owner's location, 8th floor
in Arlington Heights facing SE
gave it a completely
unobstructed line of sight,
specifically over a golf course
toward the Gaylord MGM mean.
That is a massive inherent
physical advantage.
The owner didn't have to, you
know, study radio theory.
They just benefited from
geography that delivered clean
Fresnel zones.
For listeners who might be less
familiar, that just means the
critical space around the line
of sight path was clear.
The material says it plainly.
Elevation and clean Fresnel
zones matter more than intent
that physical environment.
It does most of the work.
Then the second factor,
continuous uptime, follows from
that.
The device only became truly
consequential after the decision
to leave it permanently plugged
in and switch its role to
router.
The consistent traffic, the
message traversal that all
followed directly from
optimizing that stable physical
base, and this model success is
when things get, well, boring.
That's a compelling argument for
the necessary conditions, I'll
give you that.
But necessity is not sufficient.
Pure presence is just not
enough.
The network only gains utility
through deliberate human
intervention, configuration and
this abstraction away from the
idea of it being a personal
device.
Let's focus on what the material
calls configuration necessity.
Once a device was switched to
router mode, it introduced a lot
of friction.
The device felt unreliable.
It clashed with phone centric
expectations.
And why?
Because it defaulted to power
saving modes.
It required the owner to
actively intervene to physically
access the device over USB to
stabilize it.
This meant manually disabling
deep sleep and increasing the
Bluetooth wait time.
These were specific technical
choices made only because power
was not scarce.
If the owner had just plugged it
in and walked away, it's
unreliability would have
socially negated it's perfect
physical placement.
OK, but.
And furthermore, the human layer
is also crucial for just
managing the concept.
The initial handle Abra felt,
and I'm quoting, too personal
for something that was supposed
to function as infrastructure.
The deliberate choice to
reinterpret it as abracadabra
shows that even the identity has
to be abstracted to fit an
infrastructural role.
This is sociological work.
And finally, the utility didn't
just appear in a vacuum.
The crucial meta work, the
coordination, troubleshooting,
it all happens off network on
the centralized mesh DC discord.
That external human layer is
what dictates the network's
effective utility, not just the
radio waves.
I understand the importance
you're placing on configuration,
but I think you're confusing
alignment with ongoing
management.
I would argue that the core
stability is inherited from the
physical environment.
Elevation, unobstructive paths.
These are the fixed heavy duty
variables.
But they're not enough on their
own.
The configuration fixes you
described, disabling deep sleep,
were simply one time
adjustments.
They were needed to align the
firmware's default battery
saving behavior with the
established physical reality of
continuous wall power.
That intervention was only
necessary because that physical
reality was already guaranteed.
You're describing a single
technical decision.
I'm describing the immutable
physics that made that decision
both possible and effective.
Once the power was wall socket
stable, the real heavy lifting
of network resilience was
already done.
But that is precisely my point
about human agency.
The device defaulted to being a
poor piece of infrastructure.
If we define infrastructure by
its reliability, then the owners
active USB required intervention
to override that default state
was the act that created the
stability.
The device initially behaved
like a gadget.
It was isolating between
connected and asleep.
That unreliability is the
antithesis of infrastructure.
You're suggesting The success
was passive, but it was achieved
by technical mastery overriding
the hardware's default
constraints.
That requires A deliberate,
conscious human choice, not just
a lucky apartment.
But if the owner was living on
the ground floor with patchy
power, no amount of
configuration would fix the
physical limitations.
The configuration merely
optimized an already ideal
physical situation.
If the physics don't cooperate,
the configuration is pointless.
Physics is the prerequisite.
The physics is the foundation,
but the configuration is the
structure.
Think about the social failure
implied by unreliability.
If neighboring nodes see this
one constantly dropping out
because of default power
settings, they might actively
route around it, or worse, stop
using the mesh altogether.
The human choice to disable deep
sleep didn't just fix a
technical glitch, it fixed a
systemic social reliability
problem that would have doomed
the node regardless of its 8th
floor view.
This puts the human layer as the
ultimate point of failure or
success.
And let's pivot to visibility to
the psychology of it all.
I'd argue that the network's
adoption is reinforced by
abstraction and external
legibility.
Connecting to MQTT, which lets
the node show up on that global
map, was a key step in
transforming the owner's mindset
about what the node even was.
I'm not so sure about that.
Seeing the node as abstracted
and detached, as more legible,
it validates and encourages that
infrastructural mindset.
This metadata bubbling up to the
web, confirming the nodes
existence to the whole world.
It solidifies its collective
purpose.
Now the data link itself, it
does not affect local radio
operation, I get that.
But it's the psychological link
that confirms the note is part
of something larger, and that
encourages the continued
investment in management.
I'm just not convinced that
visibility is essential for the
network score function.
Local messaging still happens
entirely over radio.
The real metric of success was
the change in local behavior,
the shift from, you know,
occasionally detectable to
continuously present.
That was dictated by continuous
power and physics, not whether
the owner saw a blue dot on an
Internet map.
But you can't disconnect the
tech from the community.
MQTT is a display layer.
It's optional Mendo dressing.
The mesh layer is the utility
layer, and that utility is
defined by the physics of Laura
propagation.
If the local network fails to
route packets reliably, no
amount of Internet mapping will
save it.
The infrastructure exists to
forward data locally
autonomously.
Its ability to do that without
the Internet is its primary
measure of success.
But infrastructure is only
infrastructure if it's used and
maintained.
The abstract view from MQTT is a
necessary feedback loop for the
people who build and maintain
these nodes.
It gives them a sense of
participation, of impact beyond
their immediate radius.
Without that validation, the
motivation to keep that wall
power on, or to do that
difficult USB configuration in
the 1st place, it starts to
diminish.
You have to acknowledge the
human behavioral inputs that
keep the physics optimized.
Which leads us right to the
final point.
The true locus of utility and
the centralization paradox, I
argue, be the observation that
the RF layer does its job
quietly while the human layer
centralizes on discord is
actually a resounding testament
to the mesh's success.
How do you figure that?
Because the mesh's utility is
defined by its ability to route
traffic consistently and
reliably, allowing it to become
boring.
The bull is not interaction, The
goal is forwarding.
When the system just sits there
quietly routing traffic
successfully when messages
weren't just appearing, they
were traversing.
It means the fundamental
physical and configuration
decisions are stable enough that
they don't need continuous human
interaction on the RF side.
That functional independence is
the ultimate measure of
successful infrastructure.
The fact that humans centralized
on discord just proves the
hardware is doing its job,
freeing up social energy for
high level coordination.
That's a very efficient framing,
but it ignores the fundamental
fragility of the system as a
whole.
If coordination,
troubleshooting, and regional
awareness must live on a
centralized Internet required
platform like Discord, then we
have to see the local radio mesh
as just a robust but ultimately
limited transport pipe.
It's a very successful transport
pipe.
Yes, but the network as a
complete system, the community,
the governance, the ability to
adapt to new firmware, it all
depends heavily on that external
human layer.
If every time a new protocol is
rolled out or a piece of
firmware needs an urgent update,
the coordination has to happen
on a centralized server, well,
how can we truly call the
resulting system decentralized?
The physical routing is
decentralized, yes, but the glue
that transforms individual nodes
into a coherent functional
network is completely
centralized and human driven.
That is a dependency that to me
eclipses the local physics.
My thesis remains firm.
The primary value of that
Arlington Heights node stem
directly from optimizing for
physics, high placement, clear
line of sight, continuous power.
That is a hard prerequisite.
The technical decisions followed
from that physical reality.
Success is achieved when the
network becomes boring, when it
just fades into the background.
And I still maintain that the
physical layer is merely the
necessary foundation, the
ultimate utility, the stability,
the adoption.
It was all unlocked only through
complex, deliberate human
choices, conceptual abstraction
for identity, technical mastery
to override flawed default, and
the reliance on external channel
for coordination.
The stability is the result of
human will and engineering, not
just fortunate geography.
The journey of this one node
really does perfectly illuminate
that complex interplay between
robust, decentralized physical
tech and the the necessary
centralized human elements
required to make them
functionally persistent.
It forces us to recognize that
even in systems designed for
autonomy, long term success
often depends on thoughtful and
dedicated human operators making
conscious, non default technical
and social decisions.
We're still left to weigh
whether that core stability
rests on passive presence or on
active mastery.
Indeed, thank you for joining us
for the debate.